[Music]
this is Mabel Mabel is an aphid a small
insect in the same order as cicadas and
stink bugs and bed bugs all these bugs
pierce their prey and suck out by the
fluid aphids prey our plants and what
aphids are after is buried within the
plant flowing in tubes made from single
cells from end to end these are called
sieve tubes and together they form the
plumbing system for a plant's most
valuable resource SAP SAP is mostly
water and sugar
some species SAP has as much sugar per
liter as a can of soda but a synthesis
is constantly producing sugar you can
think of it as a chemical pump which
generates incredibly high pressure up to
nine times that of a car tire in the
city tubes to feed Mable uses her sis
Thailand which is a long flexible needle
she slowly worms it into the tissues
between the plant cells until she
Pierce's one of those sieve tubes
because the SAP is under so much
pressure
Mabel doesn't even have to suck it out
of the plant she just opens a valve in
her head and lets the pressure push the
sap through her digestive system we'll
come back to what comes out of her butt
but for now you should know that plants
don't want to be punctured and sipped so
they try to defend themselves
this one defense is the SAP itself see
how that works let's hypothetically hook
up some other insects digestive tract to
a steady stream of cess now when that
SAP touches the insect cells it's high
sugar content encourages the water in
the cells to come out by osmosis exactly
like salt encourages water to come out
of a slug the more sap that passes
through the insect the more water it
loses eventually it shrivels up and dies
Mabel's got however is packed with an
enzyme called sucrase which takes two
molecules of sucrose and converts them
into one molecule of fructose and one of
this three unit sugar mabel burns the
fructose for energy leaving the three
unit sugar behind now how does that
helped her the more molecules of sugar
that are dissolved in the sap the more
water it can suck out of Mabel's cells
by reducing the number of molecules of
sugar in this app Mabel reduces its
ability to suck water out of her cells
plant SAP neutralized
now that means Mabel can feed for days
getting all the energy she needs to
reproduce some a third species have an
incredible life cycle for example the
green peach aphid during the fall males
and females mate and the females lay
eggs but in the spring when the eggs
hatch all the nymphs that emerge are
female and when those females reach
maturity they don't lay eggs instead
they give birth to live young that are
clones of themselves and already
pregnant with their own clones so these
female a fadeev two generations of baby
ape and clones forming inside themselves
at the same time scientists call this
telescopic development that means that a
fits can make more of themselves fast
there can be twenty generations within a
single season and that means lots of a
fydd poop mabel can poop her entire body
weight every two hours making her one of
the most prolific poopers on the planet
some aphids can produce hundreds of
kilograms of poop per acre now a fat
poop is not likely your poop chemically
it's not all that different from SAP
it's a clear and colorless sweet syrupy
liquid you might already know it by a
different name
honeydew other species love honeydew
some species of ants love it so much
they sort of herd and defend entire a
fydd colonies in return the ants get a
steady supply of sweet honeydew which
they can drink directly from the aphids
butts
bottoms up humans love honeydew -
several Native American tribes used to
harvest
from tall reads and make it into cake
and some species of bee make honey from
honeydew which humans then harvest and
eat so plants make the SAP which is
eaten and pooped out by a feds
regurgitated by bees harvested by humans
and dollop tin to a cup if you enjoyed
learning about a feed but candy
we recommend the book ingredients which
explores the strange chemistry of what
we put in US and on us written by the
very same guy who wrote this lesson and
is speaking to you right now from
Cheetos to sunscreen you got to wonder
is that stuff bad for you and how do we
know find out more
[Music]